Sassy's Creed season yeah Josh Shaw is
here tie roots here I'm here
hi Danny we've all played Assassin's
Creed syndicate this week we did a bunch
on a live stream ty you taught me
cricket I did I taught you how to play
cricket thank you it's very important
you shoot the person who gets bulldozed
out yeah or cata in the face it's fine
ed Josh I think you play a lot more than
that did I ended up playing a like all
weekend
really yeah Wow yeah percentage you at
like 28 oh well your way yeah you're
flying yeah I'm on sequence four maybe
five now okay yeah we're not going to
talk about some specifics later in the
game I want Adam we can't talk yeah but
let's talk generally so it's a so
sweetie okay first of all it that's all
like you know let's just put a put it
out there our own assassin's creed
histories so Josh are you fine a series
yeah are you worried every assassin's
creed but I did play one and then I
thought - Kim ilanic - came along and
fixed like everything I had problem with
on one I played like a little bit of
three and then four was cool with Black
Flag yeah it wasn't called for right and
there's no black flag and then yeah I
was avoiding messing with the numbers
yeah three I didn't like four was cool
and then this one I'm kind of to unity I
didn't touch though okay or rogue ty I
might be the only person here that liked
one oh I liked one so you did okay so I
thought it was cool just yeah yeah I
mean obviously it's the same way I look
at Mass Effect right like the first one
had problems but if I still loved it I
still like Assassin's Creed one I liked
that time period to like Josh loved I
played Brotherhood did not play
Revelations yeah skip that played three
huge American history buff yeah so I was
I tried to get into it but there were
some problems there did not like Black
Flag okay I was kind of that it just
didn't fit for me yeah and the whole
Abstergo story and everything I just
wasn't there and then unity played about
maybe 10 hours oh okay and you can more
unity I have today okay I loved one to
nine oh yeah exactly right take the same
story it's like I loved it the French
Revolution is cool yeah so yeah I loved
one I love to Allah Brotherhood
revelations same thing yeah I played
maybe 15 arrows got cigarettes
yes free I wanted like didn't really get
exactly.the I was a huge like us big
history buff at the time as well yeah
and like I didn't understand anything
that's going on I loved it I mean I
liked the way they portray Washington is
is very I think they did their homework
on that like he is calm with he he's
taught in school here in the states that
he's like this renowned leader and that
he was like amazing and awesome and you
know nine times out of ten no one's
gonna talk [ __ ] about George Washington
but we're not here to talk about George
oh no we're gonna talk about this Astin
Charles goddamn Dickens and Florence
nightmares corns and the wig yeah so
like I'm also not a fan exactly I'm also
not a fan of unity and then I kind of
want this one to be good yeah and I
think the way right at the gate I was
not a fan of the early tutorial missions
it just feels to me like they just the
storytelling in these games has become
so wayward it just was way too bombastic
way too explosive and sort of sure of
itself but then once it opened up into
London the first thing I thought was
like the actual environment of London is
pretty spectacular isn't it's really
they did their homework here too I mean
that you can tell that they actually had
a lot to go off here you know like when
they made when they made London they
made the boroughs and everything else
they had pictures they had photographs
they were able to recreate my friend in
pictures yeah yeah first yeah and the
history of the other ones are too old to
have pictures so they could use as
reference yeah so now they have a good
reference point right they can recreate
London the way they want to obviously
it's not one-to-one but you know at the
same time it's like it's rented the
whole lot apart from Westminster up to
trivago square Whitehall and Buckingham
Palace it's actually like I was just
walking around going oh I bet horse card
braids right here and I was right there
and so Josh what did you think of Howard
Howard I did I mean it's kind of funny
that they've had so many of these games
and they force you through these
tutorials and it's like yeah why we know
how to play the game just like set us in
the open world and let us explore or
something is like a bit of a frustrating
start but at the end of the day I was
like it's a pretty cool game I had no
hope for this luck unity looked pretty
rough and I was like I'll just try it
out and capture the footage but like I
was I was pretty into it and like I
don't know I think that they did it this
is the second time they use the Unity
engine right so they could polish it
over the year sure there were glitches
but they weren't like they're just
normal game glitches there was like
those horrible yeah yeah
they're gonna happen in the open it kind
of looks fresher it looks a little bit
more restrained as well like it's not a
kind of looking forward to what it looks
like on PC when it's out in November and
what did you think about the actual
mission so I guess me and Ty have kind
of we've gone around the same length
into the game like not that long like
multi percent through okay I'm probably
right now as well yeah I played a bunch
more yesterday and so you're a bit
further on did you what you think of the
missions cuz I was finding them quite
like basic early on already Josh it was
weird it was really frustrating to me
because I like to play it stealth style
yeah and there's one thing I've always
hated about Assassin's Creed which is
when you walk down the street in your
normal clothes yeah and every guards
like hey you you up and in this place
you go anywhere I'm it's just people
giving you shitty wear and they
introduced the cool mechanic or you can
like put on your hood and go into
stealth mode and I thought like they'd
see you then in my java hood recognized
you and then like or like that would be
suspicious but if you were just walking
around in your normal top hat yeah why
are they recognizing me like everyone in
London knows who these twins are and
that just ruins it but you're not even
from London yeah from my shopping
there's no like Jacob yeah the fries
these secret assassin I'm somebody for
someone to be like assassino come after
you know for like it's yeah I grew Josh
it's a little I don't understand whether
he owns the stealth formula but what
about the actual like sort of in the
admissions sometimes there are some cool
like high style ones like some of the
more like sequence Enders like it'll
show you like cool is to beat it like
you can pretend to be dead or something
and like kind of beat the mission that
way the stealth stuff feel like there
are just some of those quick ones where
it's like sneak into here and it was
like I had to find this clue at a pillar
and it's like okay I could come back at
any time of day but she decides to do it
while the enemies were giving a speech
at the pillar and it was like all roped
off and it's like why would I need to do
this right now
yeah there's no reason to do it I try to
over and over over again trying to
stealth my way in and then eventually
like had all my like gang members like
attack the guards and I threw smoke
bombs everywhere oh and then one by one
I whistled and had the guys come over
and I fascinated them into the hater and
it's like this is not the most
satisfying way you could do this totally
I think that's a really good point that
I've experienced as well is it like I
feel like all the
there's like one way to complete these
missions and you got to do it that way
and coming out of like The Witcher 3 and
like Mel you're solid
yeah yeah it feels like really straight
I don't feel like I have the freedom to
figure out how to solve anything it's
like oh no you wanna you want to kill
all these people then you know you just
better I felt like I was doing it right
but it wasn't working
yeah felt like I was telling how he's
supposed to but it just they'd still see
me or whatever and it didn't feel good
and also like sometimes weird things
happen it's like that worked out all
right but in Metal Gear you know it was
set up to work like that yeah and in
this it's just like oh looks like the
game didn't stop it from stop this cool
thing from happening and the other thing
ty you were mentioning before which was
that in in we talked about it I think on
Monday would email your solid when you
and it's hard to like keep comparing it
but like this definitely does feel like
sort of a different like an old type of
open-world game as opposed to what we've
seen with The Witcher Mel gear but in
those games when if you got caught by
the guards it felt like oh everything's
changed it's like it's a charged
situation and now I have to like figure
out a way of beating them that way
within this you just mash Square to kill
them all and then people who are like 20
feet away didn't even notice you can
kill like 30 guys and then it's like
okay you're clear yeah yeah that yeah
you had it's weird cuz I think the
formula for most assassins games is like
you get caught you you piss off a guard
or you piss off a bunch of guard you
look for that line out right it's at
that one line and there's multiple paths
you can take but you you know you have
to go hide right you have to climb a
building you have to parkour over a wall
hop on a pole in this one it's kind of
cool because you can hop on a carriage
hop on a poem on a train you know well
have you guys gotten the zip lines yet
no see yes that I haven't even gotten
that yet but I've seen change a lot yeah
I didn't think I'd like it but it's
really cool and I'm sorry even L wanna
basically like like Batman hope you can
either straight up like up a building
and you can go like between buildings so
it's cool because if you're trying to
take out guards in an area you can air
assassinate them and then just like zip
right back up like out out the next one
or if he's in between buildings you can
like kind of climb across it and then be
right above them and air assassin I'm
like you can make the ledge give that
double room yeah the Devils are great
too so it's I also love the the skill
points and using Jacob and Evie
separately like you can fine-tune them
to your play style so like if you want
if you want to approach a mission super
stealth you know you can when Eevee's
better for that you know then you can
actually like kind of use your skill
points to like level her up yeah
- splits up your play style and then you
can use Jacob who's like the
over-the-top brute right who's just
gonna like [ __ ] [ __ ] up and punch stuff
around and like cause some causes a
ruckus but you know there may be a
mission that calls for that so it does
mix it up a little bit I think it gives
you a variety so that part's obvious I
think is a bonus from a plot side - like
they do they have kind of their own
agendas and so there will be like
separate missions for them have you
enjoyed the story because I've actually
found the story to be quite like but not
enjoyed an assassin's creed story
because they just jump around between
individual characters so much and I like
I remember beating black [ __ ] Black Flag
and I had no idea that was the end it
happened it's like wait this is what
I've been trying to do this whole time
it just keeps jumping from all these
like weird like capes and like eyes and
all this stuff and I think it all
happened at the end of like Revelations
because I missed a lot but they just
don't focus enough on what's going on
with the character its interests I'm
actually quite surprised that you're
you're sort of you're into it and you
played so much of it over the weekend
and it I think one of the points you
made or definitely resonated with me
which is that like I kind of went into
this with low expectations this like
this feels to me like a game like in
from the second Sun or like Batman
Arkham City where they're like oh it's
an old style of like here's a bunch of
stuff to do in a map do like they're
gonna does going to be a certain amount
of repetition there's not that many like
side quests T stuff it's kind of just
like an old style open-world game and
have fun with it yeah as opposed to like
what we've seen with other open world
games this year where it's been like
dynamic storytelling and like you know
having crazy different like ways of
attacking bases and emerging game
doesn't happen and that's what's gonna
be interesting I think about this
particular game to see how much how
different it is and how well it does
financially and how many units actually
so because the previous games like with
rogue and unity you're talking like 10
million units I think across both right
unity was the first assassins that was
specifically for the Xbox one and ps4
then they made a rogue out for the
previous gen so now is will this match
that sale total because it feels like so
it definitely feels like a game that
like an annual franchise at this stage
where it's like it's not
yeah it's a formula yeah and we'll know
now like we'll see how many units of
pushes when it releases next week I just
further saying about open world those
like I don't play this like an open
world where I like walk around and see
what's going on in the park yeah I was
like I'll go tackle I'll go rescue these
kids from this Factory I'll go like take
out this base and like each of those
little things I had some fun like
stuffing around it yes as far as open
world Oats
it's like the it's still not believable
it doesn't have that you can come
illegally unbelievable you're [ __ ]
rhyming down like these these horses can
take with a lung post to the face like
I've never seen there's a little
collectible it goes like wanton
destruction or something yeah have you
seen that so once I realize like oh I
can get that by doing lamppost I just
ride down the sidewalk let's knock him
down boom boom boom boom boom and it's a
horse running through like hundred and
trees to in it like people are just like
gormless idiots like there's dead bodies
in the street and they're like I what I
really hit what was that thing over the
bridge yesterday while I was trying to
throw a dead bodies over the bridge oh
yeah there was just three people walking
towards me in the middle of the bridge
like enemies and I threw a knife at one
of them in his face he died and the
other two people were just like chatting
to each other there's like a dead dude
on the ground then I killed the two of
them and this guy in a truck like a
horse goes up and he just stops in front
of them like I can't get past to use a
move yeah so I picked up the bodies and
tried and throw them over the bridge and
he's like waiting for me to pick up the
last body it's like yeah in like GTA
people would be screaming yeah and
running everywhere and it's like this
that attention to detail that yeah whack
sometimes it has the like environmental
attention to detail does but you're
right it does not feel like in like a
mod it's not an open world where you're
wandering around thing like ooh I wonder
what I see around this corner yeah it's
like it'll be another dozen idiot
Londoners yeah yeah I'm still it'll be a
guard yelling hey yeah you don't walk
away then I'm gonna chase you I'm gonna
knock your block like that I mean I
still want to sprint away and he's like
okay yeah okay I did my deed really
weird it's like they think you're an
assassin and they think you're [ __ ]
with them and it's only when you sprint
away that they're like oh it's fine okay
cool yeah if you're just act normal
they're like still giving you [ __ ] in
the middle of the street if they were so
recognizable they'd wear disguises like
I don't understand why they're just
walking around where every enemy knows
their faces and their clothes
that was the one thing that um that I
guess I guess it bothers been a lot of
Assassin's games but just the NPC's they
all just look this in like yeah guys
that are after you dudes look I don't
know how many like bold already guys
that yep that is there one girl model
with yes short hair she's on your team
or the enemy team they just change the
color of her clothes no so there's a
bold Bruce guy yeah and so that's
another thing they have all the
different types of enemies right they
have like the big brute guy they have
the sniper they have the scout and if if
you fight any of them you mash square
and then dodge and press X if they have
the gray bar and mash square yeah for
sex when it literally says X above their
head like it doesn't matter who it is
you just press those same buttons and
all that yeah combats not not great here
but I like it's like but it's brawler
you know if you go in with like
expectations of what this game is it is
an open world like interesting setting
it's not really pushing the yeah you
know I don't want to know the needle the
challenges are fun like the missions
have like kind of bonus challenges and I
don't get all of them but I aim for
those and that kind of gives me like I
don't even want to knock it too much in
the combat I mean the thing is it's a
it's oh I hate wreck on by it but it's
representative of the time of that error
like no one's what no one has swords
anymore like no one does that stuff so
it's like you have to adapt right but
it's the brass knuckles now and you can
punch in The Witcher but you still have
to like block like my guess is true
isn't this it's just like Eevee with her
sticks come it's kind of cool though she
has some cool animations though there
was some cool stuff that was doing with
Eevee like two days ago where like she
has like these awesome executions that I
thought were worth finishing but we'd
like to it lines and she like that's
just a nine can I got really like that I
just remember like altai year and like
the first game where it's like you work
so hard to kill one person and by the
time you're done with the tutorial with
both those characters like murdered like
50 [ __ ] that did you to run in the
first time like these people yeah but
like that would never do people are just
sociopaths and honestly thousands of
example it's kind of games in general
but I'm like I remember like in the
first games it was like oh this is like
an invading army wears like Navitus just
like street thugs so these are just
Londoners you've got families and you're
just like your game is really and and
then you I'm the worry why are you doing
it for your gang we just do the same
thing also I like as kill the guy and
then I like move the Cameron they're
just two kids like looking at it and I'm
like you know I'm supposed to be a good
guy but I just like walk away yeah okay
to me kids are the most crime-ridden
thing in his entire yeah anyway that's
our I guess impressions of Assassin's
Creed syndicate but it was alright
I don't a bash it it's nothing but it's
not bad game at all I don't think I
think it's just you know it's just
hassles Creed yeah
if you every month is a pretty good on
to that yeah I think if you know what an
assassin's Creed game is at this stage
you kind of know what's indicated yeah
but our official review will be up on
the side I believe Wednesday midnight as
well it's getting posted there's no it's
Thursday at 4:00 a.m. Thursday 4:00 a.m.
get specific pretty soon so make sure
you go back to games.com cuz you want to
see a hex areas review of that for
gamespot.com